- [Instructor] Let's say that you knew
that a jar of jellybeans
starts with 282 jellybeans,
and then you know that someone
came and ate 59 of them.
How many jellybeans would be left?
Well, you could start with
282 and then subtract 59.
And in future videos,
we're gonna think about
many different ways
to approach something like this.
How do you take 59 away from 282?
What is 282 minus 59?
But what we're going to do in
this video is not think about
what the exact number is of 282 minus 59,
but instead trying to
estimate what this is.
Instead of saying this
is equal to something,
I'm going to put these
squiggly equal signs.
And you could says 282 minus
59 is roughly equal to what?
Now, you might say, well, why is it useful
to come up with what
it roughly is equal to?
Why is estimating it actually useful?
Well, if you actually
wanted to know exactly
what 282 minus 59 is,
the estimation is useful,
because oftentimes you
can do it in your head,
and then you can see whether
your answer is reasonable.
In other situations, you
might not actually care
about the exact value of 282 minus 59.
You just wanna know roughly
how many jellybeans there are.
The typical way to estimate
when you're subtracting
large numbers is think about,
well, these numbers are
close to what other numbers
that are easier to subtract in your head?
We can start with 282.
So 282, we could round
it to the nearest 10,
and what would that be?
Well, the nearest 10 to 282
is going to be 280.
One way to think about it is
we look at the tens place.
We're either going to go
up to 290 or down to 280,
and 282 is closer to 280, so
that's why we rounded down.
And then we could do
the same thing with 59.
We have five tens here,
so we're either going
to round up to six tens
or we're gonna round down to
just five tens and no ones,
so either to 50 or 60.
And 59 is closer to 60 than it is to 50,
so this will round to 50.
There you have it.
This estimate we could say is going
to be roughly 280 minus 50.
Now, why was this useful?
Well, some of you might
find this a lot easier
to do it in your head.
In fact, I encourage
you to pause the video
and see if you can figure out
what 280 minus 50 would be in your head.
There are several ways to approach it,
but one way is to just think about
how much we have in each of the places.
So for example, we have
zero ones in either case.
That was part of the
simplification process
to get a rough estimate of what
these numbers are close to.
So we're going to, if
we have zero ones minus
and we take away zero ones,
well, we're still going to have zero ones.
That's looking at the ones place.
If we think about how
many tens we started with,
we started with eight tens,
and we're taking away five of those tens.
So if you start with eight of something
and you take away five of those tens,
you're left with three tens.
And then for hundreds, we
started with 200 jellybeans,
and we didn't take away any hundreds.
There's no hundreds right over here,
and so we're still going
to have two hundreds.
So we can say that 282 minus 59
is roughly 230,
which is useful to figuring out
if you were to actually compute this
whether you got a reasonable answer.
Or if you just wanted to
estimate, then you're done.
You're seeing, hey, this is
roughly 230 jellybeans left.